okay let's get started
my name is Lou D'Andrea and some years
ago I put together a function called
manipulate a lot of people seem to use
today I'm going to be talking about some
of the features some of the features
that are new in version 10 or version 10
awareness in manipulate and then the
second half of the talk I will be
covering synchronicity issues which is
something I've talked about before but
something that still confounds a good
number of users and for good reason it's
complicated so I'll be talking about
synchronous updating synchronous
initialization method queued method
pre-emptive those sorts of things so
let's jump in the first new intend
feature and manipulate I'd like to talk
about is tracking function so it's
always been the case that you could take
one of our control functions like slider
and rather than just having it adjust
the value of a single variable to give
the dynamic a second argument in which
you adjust that value and possibly do
some other computation some other side
effects so in this case this is a slider
that not only changes the value of x
when you change when you slide it but it
also changes the value of y so this can
be useful for a variety of reasons it's
available for all of our controls but it
was never available in manipulate
manipulates nice short syntax didn't
have a place for the second argument to
dynamic because there are no dynamics
and manipulate syntax typically you
don't specify dynamic but this was a
real shortcoming because people want to
be able to do these kinds of things in
in manipulate so now we have the
tracking function option that you can
specify so this this slider works
exactly like the one above and instead
of giving this function as a second
argument 10 I might give it as the
right-hand side of the new tracking
function option so here we have the Y
slider just changes Y but the X slider
changes both
and as I say this is useful throughout
our control language locator pain is
another very common you know locator
style manipulated variables are very
common it's common to want to restrict
them in certain ways here's an example
of a locator that you cannot move
outside of the unit circle no matter how
hard you try because as you're dragging
it it's you know the new value assigned
to this variable is coordinated through
this function and this function never
lets the norm grow past one so here we
have a trapped locator and if you have a
multi locator in manipulate so here we
start with a pair of points you can
restrain them each in different ways the
the very convenient current value that
lets you know which of the locator
thumbs you're dragging so here we have a
pair of locators one of them happens to
sit on a line one of them happens to be
inside of a circle and they each have
separate restriction functions separate
tracking functions so the first one I
can't drag off of that line and the
second one I can't drag out of that
circle so sure you could put a string
between them
fixed-length that's extra credit that
will what we'll leave that as an
exercise to the listener throughout this
notebook there are going to be some
bonus sections which I will not open
during this during the presentation this
notebook is already on the path able
site the conference website I'd
encourage you to go get the notebook
bonus section has some additional
information examples etc but I will not
be opening those sections during the
talk okay so also new in ten this didn't
quite make it into the initial release
of ten but in 1001 we have a new option
that makes manipulate aware of the
wonderful new multiple undo feature in
the front end now typically you don't
want or it's it's theoretically
impossible to undo all kernel
evaluations but there are certain
interface gestures that you can
effectively undo by resetting local
manipulate variables and you specify
which local manipulate variables you
think you should care about undo through
this new option so for example here is a
button that just for convenience does
exactly what the undo menu does and
here's a manipulate one of whose
variables is supposed to be aware of
undo now what does that mean well let's
say we changed the value of x we change
Y change X change Y and then we undo and
the changes to Y have been left alone
but the value for X steps one step back
in its own undo stack we undo again the
value of X goes back to the previous
state we guess is what happens if we
undo one more time well before this
exists before X existed there was no
output here right so this is seamlessly
in the undo chain for the notebook it's
not somehow separate in this manipulate
it's it's throughout the the undo
mechanism this is very deep technology
right so we have undo track variables we
also have a new control in version 10 we
have had for a while the ability to have
a slow
that sets one value we now have the
ability to have a slider that's that's a
pair of values and if you look in the
bonus you might see sliders that set
some other numbers of values so we have
we have you know exactly the same
control syntax that we're all familiar
with we have an interval here that we
can drag around it has all of the usual
options it has a couple of extra options
that are specific to intervals so for
instance you might care a great deal
about what happens when you try to pull
one of these slider thumbs past the
other as you've already seen initiative
alt they don't care you can pull one of
them past the other and so you can get
your intervals reversed and maybe you
don't want that maybe you do if you
don't want that you can have one of
these other method options push means
when one thumb encounters the other make
sure that it always stays less than or
equal or greater than or equal depending
on which one you're dragging and stop is
simply you know you're setting up that
other thumb as if it were the new end
point for your interval and you can't
drag past it many mathematical functions
also require a non-empty interval and if
you want to enforce that there's an
option for interval slider that says
don't let these thumbs get closer than
some distance apart so lots of functions
like plot complains if you give it an
empty plot range so this is a nod to
those functions and of course that's
interval slider in general outside of
manipulate inside of manipulate well if
you know about the control type option
you know exactly how to use this all
right you say give me a variable here's
its domain this is the control type that
I want and now it appears inside of
manipulate and it can do all the things
that intervals can do so here's an
example where there is a control that
affects the Z range of a 3d plot so here
we're specifying that the Z range
mmm scanning through here okay well
that's nice and it can also affect other
manipulate controls so here's a very
simple example a academic example of an
interval control whose value sets the
domain for some other control so this
interval control sets the domain for the
X slider so if we change
so right now X is going between about
0.3 and about 0.7 and we can change that
so that we want X only to be you know in
a very small range around 0.8 so so we
have the usual sort of self-referential
kinds of things that you might get in in
other sites of controls we have that
with interval slider as well
okay and the last new option I want to
talk about is effects the bar family of
function so we have radio button bar
setter bar there a couple of different
ways to lay these out and manipulate so
hopefully you've all seen and used them
but when you have more than a couple of
choices they get a little bit awkward
looking so the default display has them
running off the side of the page if you
know enough to set the appearance to the
word wrapping version well this is fine
but maybe some of the buttons aren't
quite as beautiful as they could be
wouldn't be nice if I could set these
all up in some sort of nice rectilinear
you know columnar a thing and now we do
have that ability so we have instead of
just appearance row horizontal vertical
we have appearance vertical dimensions
and appearance horizontal dimensions
that lets you specify I want these
things arranged in columns and I want
there to be three columns and however
many rows it takes right and this works
for all of the bar functions it works
outside of manipulate as well but I
think this is a very nice this is a very
nice adjustment to to those sets of
functions and also another nice set nice
change to checkbox bar and radio button
bar it used to be the case that you have
these beautiful displays but
you have to find the little control to
press instead of pressing anywhere on
the label and so there's a night there's
a there's a new convenience method
active that says you know go ahead and
click anywhere you want and these things
will be activated so something we could
have done from the beginning and maybe
we should have done from the beginning
and it's now available those of you that
are interested in columnar laid out may
also be interested in a new inversion
ten function multi-column that does kind
of this automatic patting and laying out
and two columns arranged either
horizontally or vertically horizontally
or vertically right okay so that ends
the new in ten half of my talk and again
all the bonus sections are staying
closed during the talk I'd encourage you
to go to the conference website and grab
the notebook or chat with me about it
afterwards
now I'd like to talk a little bit about
synchronicity so you know manipulates
flying and everything but Mathematica
lets you do evaluations that take days
how do you reconcile an interface that
the user is supposed to interact with
and get fast results you hope with
evaluations that might take you know an
arbitrary open-ended amount of time how
do you handle what what what are the
tools with which you can handle those
those situations well let's look at the
kinds of things you run into now if you
don't know about what I'm about to talk
about so if you have a first argument to
manipulate that might take a long time
well it goes off and tries and I'm using
pause here as a stand-in but this could
be you know any long-running evaluation
so it goes off and tries to do something
for a few seconds and then the front end
says eventually you know what you're
taking too long you've had enough we're
going back to the user or you might have
a single so so that's an example of an
evaluation that that is done every time
you move the slider if you had an
evaluation that just needed to be
evaluated once well maybe you think you
can isolate it in the initialization
option and say okay well I'll pay the
penalty upfront and then I'll have a
nice responsive interface well
unfortunately that didn't work because
the initialization is also subject to
this
worked timeout and you and you see other
places where you might have long-running
evaluations so what do you do in this
case what's actually happening here and
and what are the what are the tools that
you're at your that you can use to deal
with this okay so one of the things
before we get to the tools one of the
things to realize is that starting in
that let me say it this way before
version six in Mathematica five and
before the front-end and kernel
communicated over a single math link
there was only one line of communication
between the kernel in front end and that
was your evaluation queue that's how
your evaluation queue was was handled
but starting in version six as maybe
some of you know we now have multiple
links connecting the front-end in kernel
which allow us to do things like this
while the kernel is saturated sitting
this while loop doing nothing but
waiting and printing I can still
interact with an interface that goes off
and uses the kernel so how is this
happening what features are built into
Mathematica that allow this kind of
thing to happen and it's the it's the
communication over multiple links that's
the key and there so there are there are
two main ways in which the front-end and
kernel communicate with one another and
for purposes of this talk I'll call them
synchronous and asynchronous synchronous
updating is the new thing we invented in
version six that allows this sort of
fast updating while the kernel is
otherwise busy so we have the ability to
do pre-emptive evaluations
you know the kernel is busy but you can
still ask it to do something these
evaluations are intended to be very fast
they're expected to be very fast and so
the front end has things has nice has
has ways of making them even smoother by
hiding all of the additional bells and
whistles that you usually associated
with evaluations like cell brackets
highlighting running appearing in the
title none of that happens for
pre-emptive evaluations but also the
front end completely waits while
this evaluation is happening so it's
it's not only intended to be fast but if
it's not fast then the whole front end
will wait for you we'll wait for this
evaluation to return and because of that
we can't wait forever
I think the default timeout is something
like 6 seconds so this is this is sort
of the default mode for dynamic the
default vote mode from any controls it's
not the default mode for shift return
evaluations shift return or asynchronous
evaluations they sit in first in first
out queue they they can handle
evaluations that run for days you get
cell bracken indications running in the
in the title bar you get this preempt
ability that we talked about and of
course you can keep typing while your
evaluation is running so how do you
access these two different evaluation
modes inside of the dynamic language and
in particular inside of manipulate so
inside of the dynamic language we have
an option to dynamic which basically
says use synchronous updating for this
dynamic or use asynchronous updating the
default is synchronous which times out
after a few seconds so here is a minimal
example of that dollar aborted also
notice the spinning beach ball the front
end is completely waiting for the kernel
to respond here right that it finally
says after 6 seconds
sorry that's enough and we have a
different indicator when you have a so
an asynchronous dynamic notice the SEL
bracket is lit up we have a place now
that's reserved for the result when it
comes back and eventually it comes back
and populates so synchronous updating is
a dynamic option it's also a manipulate
option we looked at initializations
there is a similar flag that lets you
say whether or not you want an
initialization to run synchronously so
here we have we have the default mode
which is yes I want this initialization
to be synchronous but of course that's
going to timeout we have noticed we have
no indication that it timed out other
than the value of X didn't become one
and manipulate you have some indication
and dynamic module the lower level
primitive you do not
but if you set synchronous
initialization false then okay you have
this synchronous dynamic which shows X
to be zero the initialization is still
turning away and when it's done you see
the value of X has changed again
synchronous initialization is a dynamic
module box option it's also a manipulate
option so if you have manipulated
initializations you can use it a few
other controls are aware of the two
different evaluation modes button and
action menu have a method option which
lets you specify queued evaluations
versus pre-emptive evaluations and by
default they are pre-emptive but if you
have long-running evaluations say you
have a button that goes off and hits the
network and you don't know what your
network latency is going to be or you
have something that opens a dialog box
and ask the user for something you
should always use method queued in that
case an action menu and button are the
two that that can do that and file name
setter
there's not even choice for method
because it always opens a dialog so it
always has method queued burned-in right
so in short manipulate uses the same
defaults for synchronous initialization
the dynamic module box does it uses a
new default for a synchronous updating
automatic which actually allows the
front-end to switch back and forth
between synchronous updates and
asynchronous updates as it sees fit I'm
going to skip a couple of sections here
and go straight to the icing control
active is the way that you interact with
that synchronous updating automatic and
you specify which are the fast rendering
and the slow rendering bits so here we
have a control well let me point out
control active first argument is the
thing that evaluates quickly it will
happen over the preemptive link and be
expected to be fast
the second argument happens or the
queued link can take as long as it wants
and these automatically swap back and
forth while you're interacting with
control so while the control is active
you're seeing the draft fast the first
argument and as you release then notice
that the cell bracket lit up briefly
when I released that's because that last
update is and is an asynchronous update
right so rule of thumb whenever you have
a long-running thing whenever you have
to ask the user something whenever you
might hit the network make sure that you
think about synchronous updating and
synchronous initialization and there are
more and more functions in Mathematica
that hit the network there's quantity
sometimes it's the network entity
sometimes it's the network Geographics I
think sometimes it's the network
WolframAlpha we have data packet
functions so it's important to keep this
distinction in mind I think right so
that is basically what I wanted to cover
thank you for your attention and I think
we have a few moments for questions